[Music]
cars three yeah why not
I mean okay I can think of a lot of
reasons why not but here it is so might
as well look it over as a lot you know I
didn't really care for the previous cars
movies in fact I think Cars 2 is one of
the worst films Pixar's ever made but
some people were telling me that Cars
three was different it was more adult it
was more grown-up it's the best of the
movies and yeah out of the movies I
guess that's true but given the low bar
they said I don't think that's any real
big accomplishment Lightning McQueen is
back to racing on no more spy stuff what
a shame but he discovers a younger racer
named Jackson storm is breaking his
records and eventually even McQueen
himself getting horribly injured on the
racetrack McQueen decides to leave
racing for a while
disappearing into his old town home
wondering if he'll ever race again he
decides he does want to race but he
knows that if he's going to he needs to
make some changes getting a high-end
sponsor behind his back he gets a new
trainer new location new equipment the
whole shebang he starts to become
reckless though being treated like an
old-timer and tries rushing the process
after finding he can't handle a lot of
the training equipment the sponsor
suggests maybe he should pull out of the
race and they'll still get him some
branding McQueen disagrees though and
goes on his own to do his own kind of
training much to the trainers dismay she
follows him but has trouble keeping up
as it's on different types of roads like
sand and dirt and so forth as they hang
out more together he discovers more
about her past and her ambitions and of
course they find they have a lot in
common and they come together for a
compromise so yeah let's see you we have
a red car who's lost his way and so he
takes some time away training and
getting in touch with what really
matters and sounds a little familiar huh
oh there's a big race at the end and
there's a twist about not being so
selfish yeah don't say ok to the film's
credit it really isn't a huge repeat of
the first cars film I mean first of all
there is more effort put in it isn't
exactly one of those stories where you
know from beginning to end exactly
what's gonna happen but the downside is
it's not really a story where you want
to know exactly what's gonna happen
either there's a lot of sitting around
and talking surprisingly enough don't
get me wrong when a lot of Pixar films
do that
usually done very well and is very
encouraged but it's still cars three its
Owen Wilson going Wow every other second
no seriously somebody do a WoW count on
this movie I think a broken record even
for Owen Wilson there's not a ton of
creativity or excitement or even that
many laughs that's just sort of them
talking about what really matters and
talking about different training
techniques what works what doesn't
honestly looking it over it seems more
like the virtual reality stuff was doing
better that's how the other guy got in
the lead and how many times you're gonna
race on the beach or in the forest or
anything like that doesn't it make sense
to master the racetrack it's like an
opera singer learning how to do rap okay
it's good to broaden your horizons but I
just don't see that much crossover the
only time where I saw a legit amount of
creativity is when he was doing some
dirt racing the designs of a lot of
these cars especially this school bus
we're really creative and fun to look at
but aside from that the story and
characters aren't really riveting enough
for adults and it's not really goofy or
fun enough for kids
no again that's not to say it's awful
and this is coming from a guy who really
hated the first two car films you can
tell the filmmakers really cared about
what they were saying and writing and
animating and the performances but it's
just stuff we've seen in other sports
movies nothing new is really added the
fact that their cars is still
distracting it really doesn't add
anything to the world I still don't
fully understand how this world works
finding climax well character driven
still doesn't make a whole lot of sense
who you want to let someone else race
great why don't you do that with someone
else's money who's paying millions of
dollars to brand you this just seems
like a douchey move and the explanation
they have for how they got away with it
still seems dumb so was I pulling my
hair out at it no did I hear a ton of
bad jokes a couple but not that many is
it as annoying and or bland as the
previous cars films not by a longshot
but they still can't say I was bad
entertained I guess if you like the car
movies and you kind of want a more adult
take on it this does okay if you have a
soft spot for some of these sports and
training cliches you'll get through it
alright but I don't know how many kids
would be that excited for this story and
I don't know how many adult would be
that excited for this
taury I guess out of the cars movies
this one is the best but given its
background it's not much of a race to
win
[Music]